who do you trust new york times who else
cmn
maybe even fox news except don't trust
any of them i don't trust any of them
they're all full of [ __ ]
if nothing else with this current
election i think that we've seen
the current media establishments bias on
display for all to see i'm not drawing a
moral equivalency between either the
candidates here and this does not mean
that i'm going to stop mocking all of
them as we've done which in internet
land is blasphemy
if you look at the media coverage
it's tough to know exactly i've seen
numbers as high as 90 percent negative
coverage of trump versus hillary i've
seen as high as 10 to 1 ratios of
coverage of trump's sexual harassment
allegations versus wikileaks i think
everybody at this point even knows
including leftists that the media is
trying to drag their cackling corpse
that is hillary clinton across the
finish line
so i want to give you some concrete
examples that i think can be fairly put
side by side for comparison in how the
media has handled
trump scandals and hillary clinton
scandals first up the sex stuff i think
it goes without saying
that everybody knows about the infamous
wrapping by the [ __ ] which is still
funny so donald trump said this he was
caught saying this he paid the price for
saying this nobody is denying that he
said this but the cascade that followed
this with allegations completely
unsubstantiated which dominated the
airwaves bringing the wikileaks that
entire time got to the point of being
absurd think about the new york times
feature for a second a woman simply
comes forward says donald trump reached
up my skirt in a 747 40 something odd
years ago and it gets published front
page new york times that's it nothing
else was needed they dined on that for a
week i'm not saying it's okay to do that
in first class if you do it do business
class you're just between the middle
you're under the radar have you ever
been in a
in a turkish prison think donald think
some of these may be true some people
may have ulterior motives the truth is
probably as usual somewhere in the
middle let's contrast that with the
media's handling of the clinton's long
and storied history of sexual abuse now
there are so many examples from
inappropriate touching to flat-out
allegations of rape which have been
ignored by the media so let's try and
limit it to the ones that directly
involve hillary because bill's not
running for office now many young people
only know the name monica lewinsky and
you don't think that it's a big deal
that the president of the united states
used his position of power for sexual
favors from a young
if slightly rotund intern ruining a
perfectly good green dress blue
blue she would have looked better in
green what about the names of paula
jones sally perdue catherine wiley
jennifer flowers juanita broderick among
others who have come forward with actual
allegations of rape allegations that
were more substantiated than the current
ones against donald trump how does
hillary clinton tie into this well she
dismissed the accusers
against her husband as
bimbo eruptions the washington post not
known for being right-leaning wrote she
discredited claims later revealed to be
true and worked behind the scenes to
help manage the allegations of course
when it was convenient for her hashtag
i'm with her she's breaking through the
glass ceiling she said that all victims
of sexual assault deserved to be
believed when asked that the sentiment
applied to all of her husband's accusers
many of whom came forward in court some
of whom with which they had to settle
huge amounts of cash she said and i
quote i would say that everybody should
believed it first
until they are disbelieved on evidence
also hillary clinton defended a child
rapist and laughed about it you're the
devil and that dog is a hell beast
second example the media's handling of
the trump foundation versus the clinton
foundation now the trump foundation has
absolutely had some problems for example
using foundation funds to bail out
donald trump or family members
personally they failed to register as a
non-profit in certain states prior to
fundraising and none of this is good but
if if this is here and newt gingrich is
here um hillary clinton is you can't
even you can't even see we don't have a
big enough lens it's too small believe
me i didn't need a camera that would get
it oh oh what that figured it
the clinton foundation whose board is
made up of all the clinton's closest
buddies with no oversight committee no
term limits for board members and really
just no outside voices other than the
clintons
and people who don't want to get whacked
sorry
the litany of things we could go through
with the clinton foundation sometimes
donations being made when she gives
private speeches exchanging of monies
that you see in a lot of non-profit
foundations but the biggest problem of
course is the clintons
shamelessly accepting a foreign donation
for those who don't know that's not just
frowned upon it's illegal it's highly
illegal and some of these donations come
from foreign entities in the middle east
who have a vested interest in seeing the
toppling of the united states the
clintons in this campaign who have so
much more money than donald trump
are funded in part by foreign countries
who want you and i to die or
start facing mecca five times a day
which reminds me sorry excuse me
[Music]
of course let's not forget about the
2010 haiti earthquake relief funds which
just mysteriously vanished
should have thought of that before you
tried to join forces with the clintons
and your haitian voodoo you've made your
bed
now lie in it number three this one's
pretty significant the media's handling
of donald trump's tax returns versus
wikileaks to set the stage if only the
media had demanded the release of
hillary's emails half as ardently as
they wanted the release of donald
trump's tax returns now i'm not saying
that donald trump shouldn't have
released his tax returns it is customary
and i would have liked to see them but i
really would have liked to see the
emails what did we learn from the
wikileaks emails well you can click
right here on my in-depth video with the
top five wikileaks revelations which
included media collusion the clinton
foundation all kinds of stuff with
podesta how they screwed bernie sanders
and that barack obama knew about the
private email server but the media
barely covered it and their
justification was it's illegal to
possess uh these stolen documents it's
different for the media okay that's true
but how are donald trump's tax returns
procured the trump tax returns were
stolen as well when they were mailed to
the new york times you guys didn't
object to that in fact you jumped all
over them but we don't know where those
tax returns come
we don't know where those tax returns
came from we're pretty sure wikileaks
was the russians we're pretty sure
the tax returns from donald trump
came from little john and the apprentice
robbie mook what a mook was a layup i'm
sorry again i'm not justifying either
person lying on either of these fronts
what i am talking about here this is key
let's continue with this is the media's
treatment of the candidates and how
wildly different it is number four
violence at rallies and or at the center
of the campaigns of course the media
jumped all over michelle fields corey
lewandowski's rough handling of her
which i think was at least inappropriate
and of course the media ran with the
stories for weeks on donald trump
inciting violence at rallies you've all
seen the tapes none of that's okay we
talked about that too but now we've seen
on camera from project veritas that the
dnc and left-leaning non-profit
organizations have deliberately
proactively repeatedly sent in agitators
to trump rallies to incite violence
trump rallies
we're starting anarchy here the campaign
pays dnc dnc pays democracy partners
democracy partners pace the global group
the fomo group
goes and executes the shot donald trump
says i'd like to put shelby to the face
media dines out on it for a week what do
they say when this happens on camera no
evidence whatsoever
that we have been able to find that
anyone ever did anything like this when
they were working uh for the dnc for
reference no evidence whatsoever is
actually a synonym for i don't like your
question jake and i won't respond to it
which brings us to number five our final
point attacks
against free speech and the press this
is where people get mad at me being
even-handed but my biggest problem with
donald trump has been his repeated
attacks on the press threatening to sue
and expanding the libel laws as it
relates to the first amendment you
already can't slander libel is illegal
and there are courses of action to take
donald trump has taken them many times
the first amendment not only to what we
do here but to any american is paramount
and we need to demand 100
adherence and respect to the first
amendment as it exists so the media will
trot out over 3 500 lawsuits from trump
which granted it is a lot uh but a lot
of those are business related or somehow
political they don't all involve the
media right now he's been threatening to
see the new york times or these
publications that have had women come
forward without any kind of evidence or
substantiation now you don't have the
right and i don't want a candidate who
sues for negative coverage or because
someone says something about him that he
doesn't like but if someone is coming
forward saying this man raped me and
there's no proof and it's being run as
fact and the people running that know
there's no proof that is liable that is
slander but the first amendment doesn't
need to be expanded there are already
laws for that let's be clear hillary
clinton however wants to eradicate the
first amendment as it stands through a
constitutional amendment we've talked
about this she wants an amendment to
overturn citizens united which was an
amendment to protect free speech as it
relates to censorship of political views
i'm not saying there aren't flaws with
the implementation of citizens united
what is important here is citizens
united was ruled on by the supreme court
specifically because hillary clinton was
trying to use a loophole law to silence
a film that was critical of her at its
core citizens united exists because the
clinton mafia tried to squash
independent filmmakers under their giant
fat boots
feeling citizens united would be
antithetical to exactly why the first
amendment exists to protect political
speech yes it protects all speech but it
was designed to protect political and
religious speech not so much nazi memes
or pornography on the internet though
that too and this is what's so important
the media who've jumped all over trump
for wanting to sue women who've come
forward with no evidence and allegations
of rape not only are fine with the
reversal of citizens united they support
hillary clinton media people who are
supposed to be informing you are
actively advocating on how to do away
with the first amendment you had one job
to do double secret irony alert one of
my favorite quotes from hillary clinton
for me it means that we need a supreme
court that will stand up on behalf of
women's rights on behalf of the rights
of the lgbt community i guess she didn't
have the aaip at that point will forgive
it that will stand up and say no to
citizens united a decision that has
undermined the election system in the
country because of its way of permitting
dark unaccountable money to come into
our electoral system as dark
unaccountable money from outside sources
you know we've seen that uh with donald
trump to the tune of about 40 million um
with hillary clinton 143.
million and the money's coming your way
you don't ask any questions that's
what's so funny about the citizens
united talk you have silly bernie voters
and young people who talk about getting
money out of politics and citizens
united has become a buzzword right well
there are two components you're talking
about money in politics big money in
politics a lot of people are upset by
that guess what no one in the history of
the united states has benefited from
citizens united in that sense more than
the clintons but at its core citizens
united is about free speech the clintons
want to do away with the aspect of
citizens united that protect free speech
they want to keep the foreign donations
to the tune of 140 million while doing
away with the right of private
independent filmmakers to create a film
exposing hillary clinton this is the
kind of corruption that the head writers
couldn't even feather into the
underwood's narrative for fear of it
being unbelievable democracy is so
overrated
listen i get that many of you out there
feel that you have no good choice in
this election you're exhausted with the
whole process and i'm not going to tell
you who to vote for because i'm not just
worried about 2016. i'm hoping that this
election will at least allow people to
break the cycle and see the blatant
corruption and collusion that has
happened with both mainstream media and
alternative social media as we're seeing
now if anything you've heard in this
video
is new to you uh the references are
available at lottowithcrider.com but
guess what you're probably not informed
enough to vote correctly all of this is
so pivotal that none of it should be new
to you and you have to ask yourself
why didn't i know this how am i missing
this because when you dig to the bottom
of it you're left with two answers
either one that's scary
because you realize you've been
proactively lied to and you have to ask
yourself how long has this been going on
or
a second scenario which well which is
also scary um
that you're learning disabled and you
never
[Music]
hey if you like this video subscribe i'm
shaking my bosoms for you i'm going to
continue
doing see i can't even speak because the
bosom shaking is ruining my word play
i'm going to keep doing this until you
hit one of the boxes there's a subscribe
button below lottowithcrider.com for
references by clicking my face or there
are two videos next to us another one's
a top five list and another one is the
full show my nipples are bleeding